it's not a surprise that the idea for a
brand new European newspaper started
here in the small city of norwich in the
East of England after all the people of
Norwich wanted to stay in the European
Union whereas the rest of the region
voted solidly for brexit the paper was
originally only for sale in areas with
pro-eu majorities but it since become
available in some 40,000 news agents
across the country it costs two pounds
the Archon media companies behind the
venture the idea for the newspaper came
from its chief content officer we
believe that we're better together we
believe that the UK is a better country
if it's open to to to Europe in that way
and that's the fight will keep pursuing
issues covered include EU policy and the
fallout from brexit it even features
competitions offering european beer as a
prize it's chosen to remain old-school
appearing in print and not digitally
people who were feeling really annoyed
could visibly carry around the new
European and say look you know I'm one
of the forty-eight percent that was the
idea cuz we put something in print
people would want to buy and carry
around and use as a badge of honor but
this isn't so much a political venture
as a business opportunity the newspaper
started out with minimal funding it
emerged as a pop-up paper shortly after
the referendum the work was done by
people who already work for the
organization so we have no staff
directly apportioned to the project the
marketing budget was set at 20,000
pounds for launch and really the only
extra costs were print paper
distribution but the big question is
have any wrecks of tears ever bought the
paper only to burn on street corners
also wrap their fish and chips and also
do things that you wouldn't want to hear
off and they keep telling us about it on
Twitter but as long as they keep paying
the two pounds I don't care
and every pound house the publishers say
the newspaper will be scrapped if it
stops turning a profit but it doesn't
look like this at the moment